for everybody here AI will be incredibly
impactful for the rest of your lives in
10 years as we are still working AI will
be profound if you decide to be an
ostrich and put your head in the sand
and not worry about it instead of
spending 20 hours of your own research
time on the internet instead of headline
reading a couple things and saying it's
good b or indiffer to not spend 20 hours
to actually understand what's going on
in AI would be grossly negligent
professionally and I highly encourage
you to pour a beer or a glass of wine or
a cocktail or do it this holiday season
find the 20 hours before 2024 starts to
actually know what you're talking about
because I think we can all agree with
technology much like a lot of things in
life we become headline readers and we
make our decisions based on a couple
headlines without actually knowing what
we're talking about and for everybody
here AI will be incredibly impactful for
the rest of your
lives